carteles música y camisas blancas así se
veía la marcha de cerca de dos mil
salvadoreños que se dirigían hacia la
frontera con guatemala incitando a que
los jóvenes se queden en el país el lema
yo me quedo en el salvador los objetivos
concientizar de los riesgos de emigrar
ilegalmente y hacer un llamado a la
generación de nuevas oportunidades para
la juventud en el país representan a
millones de salvadoreños que quieren
quedarse en el país que quieren quedarse
en el salvador pero que es fundamental
tener otras condiciones de vida tener
otros proyectos
organizaciones salvadoreñas alertan que
entre 200 y 300 personas abandonan
diariamente el país además la
organización internacional para las
migraciones calcula que cerca del 65 por
ciento de las personas que fueron
deportadas hacia el salvador en el
primer trimestre de este año migraron
por factores económicos 22 por ciento
para reunificar a sus familias y 12.4
por ciento debido a la inseguridad si la
vez en las malas condiciones verdades
sociales políticas y otros factores
obligan verdad muchas de nuestras
hermanas salvadoreños a buscar
desarrollo en otros en otros territorios
verdad
a pesar de las promesas esperanzadoras
hacia la juventud de nadie bukele cerca
de 33% de la población vive en la
pobreza
una que lejos de disminuir ha aumentado
desde la crisis sanitaria del cobi 19